tu entends ce message tu es là les
nôtres situé l'année m tu peux les
trouver
[Musique]
bientôt il n'y aurait plus aucun enfant
nulle part le gouvernement n'avait pas
peur de ceux qui étaient morts ils
avaient peur de nous car ceux qui
avaient survécu avait changé rugby les
jeunes comme toi sont vraiment rares
j'ai fait partie des plus puissants
mais là où on va les jeunes vivent
ensemble elyma mais celles qui sont
prêts à nous aider
seydoux
surtout tu t'arrêtes pas
pour leur sécurité la vôtre vous devez
nous livrer vos enfants je suis assez
malin pour voir que tu caches quelque
chose est assez maligne pour le kg je
voulais pas que vous ayez peur de moi
plus je sais de me contrôler
et plus devient dangereuse
peut aider à maîtriser des facultés pour
qu'ils puissent s'en servir
[Musique]
opus battre
on n'est plus obligé de se cacher on a
survécu à tout ça
je me battrai pour nôtre aussi
[Musique]